pas
attrape du 19 au 24 novembre l'éducation
est mise en avant
c'est à l'occasion de la signature du
projet éducatif de territoire que la
ville
promeut tout ce qui est fait en termes
d'éducation donc il ya des ateliers des
projections des rencontres et au cinéma
le grenier à sel
il y aura le vendredi 23 novembre à
20h45 la projection d'un documentaire
qui s'appelle une idée folle qui pose la
question du rôle de l'école 21e siècle à
travers le témoignage d'enseignants
d'enfants de parents ainsi que d'experts
de l'éducation la réalisatrice viendra
donc vendredi 23 novembre à 20h45 au
cinéma le grenier à sel tous nos déchets
par exemple à la cantine rue des
plaisirs est vendée mais là dedans il a
osé le demander mais l'on dort fruits on
leur apprend à être pour être dans la
construction pas être contre à toujours
se plaindre toute leur vie que mon dieu
c'est horrible tout ce qui m'arrive mais
ça va pas non mais qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour que ça bouge tienne
citoyenneté en actions mois
et puis quand on sera plus grands on
fera plus des petites choses mais on
fera des grandes choses d'une plus
grande pour essayer de plus changé
[Musique]